il passe partout n'est pas n'importe où
carte accroché au guidon
ces cyclistes en vtt sont lancés dans
une course d'orientation
objectif rallier des balises dispersés
en forêt le plus rapidement possible et
gagner son ticket pour les championnats
du monde le mois prochain d'un coup tout
seul et je vois que l'orientation a là
rien à voir je vais avoir à laisser
monter ou donc là je cogite je jouais
bien je suis ici baptiste fuchs compte
dix sélections en équipe de france
trois titres de vice champion du monde à
son palmarès cette année c'est lors
qu'il vise
j'avais fait le choix de mettre un petit
peu entre parenthèses l'année dernière
le haut niveau est bas il se trouve que
de toute façon il ya ulcos vite donc il
s'est pas passé grand chose mais voilà
reprendre les automatismes c'est un
c'est pas évident donc on a un petit peu
dans l'incertitude mais globalement bon
là je trouve que c'est
c'est un peu comme le vélo quand on
n'oublie pas tant que ça le haut niveau
gthn alors et hui le découvre à 15 ans
c'est sa deuxième participation à des
sélections somme représente une
opportunité pour avoir de l'expérience
et pour pour pouvoir m'entraîner me
surpasser en quelque sorte pour avoir de
meilleures performances et comme ça
après je peux partir à l'étranger voir
de nouveaux paysages
ça apporte plein de choses au total 35
participants aux sélections seuls 7
pourront représenter la france aux
mondiaux sur les chances de médaille
tricolore
l'entraîneur des bleus se montrent
prudents mais confiants sept seniors qui
valent ils sont dans les trois minutes
en trois minutes 17 sont
on fait quasiment en même temps donc ils
ont un niveau très haut niveau très
dense ce qui prouve que le niveau est
très bon en bus et on pourrait faire on
pourrait faire hambourg est très bons
résultats
ces sélections dans le loiret se
poursuivre jusqu'à dimanche au programme
notamment courses et exercices de
simulation